on sait depuis quelques années le
chanteur francis lalanne s'engage de
plus en plus dans la vie politique du
pays
les actifs au moment dé gilet jaune lors
de ses différentes interventions
médiatiques francis se montrent souvent
très virulents à l'encontre du
gouvernement ce que c'est eux qui créent
la violence un cc qu'à scanner et mâcon
quitterait la violence c'est le cas par
exemple lors d'une tribune publiée le 22
janvier par france soir une tribune dans
laquelle francis lalanne lancé un appel
à un coup d'état
je demande aux plus grands responsables
militaires français de mettre fin à
l'exercice du mandat de l'actuel
président de la république
le chanteur était venu dans tpm paix
pour s'expliquer sur ses déclarations
passage durant lequel les échanges avec
les autres intervenants avaient été
particulièrement tendus
sauf qu'aujourd'hui cette affaire
médiatique est devenu une affaire
politique
une enquête aurait été ouverte sur le
chanteur pour atteinte aux intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation
une attente qui pourrait lui coûter
jusqu'à 5 ans de prison et 45000 euros
damende alors francis lalanne mérite
t-il la prison
36' jeunes méritent ils la prison merci
eric naulleau d'être avec nous très chic
vraiment d'être à la hauteur de
l'émission on va vous êtes toujours à la
hauteur et on a maître emmanuel ludot
merci d'être là à mettre un soir si vous
êtes là faut 4 consiste la lan
alors c'est vrai que cette affaire elle
est complètement folle parce que ça
prend des proportions incroyables
on va en parler avec vous dans un
instant juste eric naulleau pour vous
c'est pas des proportions incroyables
pour vous c'est normal et vous pensez
que français de la main a été trop loin
a été trop loin oui moi je souhaite
qu'il réponde de ses propos devant la
justice mais je ne souhaite pas qu'il
aille en prison
et je suis désolé de tuer le suspense
mais il n'ira pas en prison
on joue à se faire peur bien sûr en
revanche qu'il doit répondre de ses
propos j'ai été vraiment mon opinion
tout à l'heure mais pour moi ça me
semble normal évidemment mais quand vous
trouvez qu'il était était trop vague a
beaucoup de gens qui se sont offusqués
contre cette tribune dans françois parce
que c'est vrai qu'il appelé à la
désobéissance il était venu ici aussi
voilà mais est-ce que penser que ça peut
aller jusqu'à voilà pensez pas que c'est
c'est disproportionné lalanne se prend
pour zola
j'appelle jacques eu un problème c'est
que ces eaux là à la portée des caniches
il ya deux attitudes possibles soit on
estime que l'état a sorti un marteau
piqueur pour écraser un moucheron et
ondimba laissons lalanne délire et de
son côté soit on considère que les mots
ont une signification et que les lois en
leur raison d'être dans cette dans cet
appel un peu fourre-tout il ya un peu de
tout il va un peu dans tous les sens
il ya un moment quand même l'appel à un
coup d'état militaire il appelle à
débarquer le président de la république
par l'armée excusez moi c'est quand même
gravissime
alors si on laisse passer on laisse
passer tout mais regardez ce qui s'est
passé un homme un jour et rideaux et
ancien gilet jaune il appelle à
rechercher sur l'elysée l'autre jour ces
générations identitaire qui veut faire
la police à la place de la police et m'a
lancé lalanne qui appelle l'armée à
dégager près le présent la réplique dans
chacun bricole dans son coin sa petite
île légalité et ça devient la chienlit
moi je pense qu'il faut dire stop que la
lan reviennent sur terre et là il plane
trop pour nous qu'il revienne sur terre
qu'il réponde de ses actes devant la
justice mais évidemment je le répète
qu'il n'aille pas en prison
là ce serait vraiment disproportionnée
et c'est vrai que m il était traumatisé
par son passage sur notre émission alors
que je trouvais que c'était plutôt on
l'avait laissé beaucoup la parole après
ses réponses il a une sensibilité
voilà exacerbée c'est vrai que j'aime
beaucoup et ça me fait de la peine en
tout cas parce que voilà c'est quelqu'un
qu'on aime bien quand même voilà et
merci en tout cas à vous d'être venu
qu'est ce que vous dites sur cette
tribune appelant à la désobéissance de
francis lalanne est sûre aujourd'hui ce
qui risque qu'ils encourent
parce que ce que je dis c'est simple
c'est que il faut il faut redescendre
sur terre
c'est ce que vous disiez cccc quelqu'un
d'enflammer joel francis lalanne c'est
quelqu'un souvent d'exalter donc il faut
effectivement lui dire non voilà ça va
trop loin
c'est l'artiste qui parle c'est le
sentimental qui s'exprime alors ce texte
là pour vous dire les choses clairement
et sincèrement s'il me l'avait présentée
avant je pense qu'il serait pas tout à
fait du même tonneau
franchement bravo pour votre franchise
non mais c'est vrai mais mais c'est fait
c'est fait voilà alors qu'est ce qu'il a
voulu dire
il ya deux parties d'un sens dans son
texte la première partie il dit
j'en appelle au parlement ça c'est pas
méchant c'est pas des belges et une
partie d'ici le parlement fait rien
alors il va falloir effectivement se
retrousser les manches et ils visent un
texte du code de la croix tuer la
constitution qui qui discutable sur le
plan de la constitution c'est très
discutable bon la question c'est de
savoir s'il avait l'intention
effectivement de commettre un délit ou
s'ils n'avaient pas l'intention de le
faire alors comme il ya eu ce battage
médiatique terrible et tout ça c'est
monté en mayonnaise
le parquet qui a été pressé par les
journées sans le dire alors qu'est ce
que vous faites qu'est ce que vous
faites vous laisser ça là où laisser ça
là le parquet a dit allez on va calmer
le jeu on va l'entendre
et puis on va bien voir ce qui va nous
dire alors oui il a été entendu
joyal il a dit il a dit pas où je
demande à l'armée française de prendre
toutes les mesures concernant les
auteurs du coup d'état visant à faire
respecter les décisions de justice qui
seront prononcées à leur endroit
il faut à présent mettre l'état d'état
de nuire une la phrase aurait dans sa
trace depuis la france
oui moi j'appelle les plus hauts
dignitaires de l'armée française du
peuple et à faire cesser le trouble
social et politique dont souffre depuis
trop longtemps la nation ce qui m'a dit
ça c'est dans l'hypothèse où le
parlement voilà enfin c'est son analyse
sur un coup d'état militaire
moi maintenant je vais vous expliquer en
donnant mon point de vue il faut choisir
son camp
on est dans un état de droit si vous
avez des idées politiques à apporter
vous présenter devant le suffrage
universel
c'est ce qu'a fait francis l'aiment il a
recueilli 0,54 point porte non pas peu
importe parce que comme il n'a pas
réussi c'est pas là la régulière dans
des élections régulières maintenant ils
en appellent à un coup d'état il faut
choisir son camp ses mannequins dans la
légalité
nous assurons nous sommes dans le coup
d'état c'est pas le problème le problème
je pense qu'il est plus grave que ça
d'abord je vais vous dire on a eu
l'enquêteur j'étais avec lui
j'en ai discuté avec l'enquêteur moi je
suis pas du genre à prendre les
policiers rebrousse poil j'aime bien
parler j'aime bien on va voir et puis à
la discussion
il m'a dit on et c'est pas la sphère du
siècle non j'ai autre chose à faire que
ça non plus fait dire au procureur de
classer cette affaire et on va la classe
et non d'alzheimer elle va classer
l'affairé va être classé bien sûr moi ce
qui me gêne bien sûr qu'avec là c'est
moi ce qui me gêne là c'est c'est la
liberté d'expression on a le droit de
dire des sottises en france heureusement
sinon je serais pas là parce que c'est
ce que j'ai dit à lalinde j'ai dit
attendez vous vous appelez vous
critiquer le pouvoir aller faire un tour
en corée du nord
allez faire un tour en birmanie donc ça
lui remet ça mais les choses en place
mais c'est ce que je parle avec les élus
âgées du mot dictature quelqu'un en
effet dans la langue de la lan une
installation qui vivent sous une vraie
juste ce qu il reprenne les plus les
plus radicaux ceux qui pensent que
francis lalanne peretti la prison alors
ils vont loin gilles verdez et nicolas
pernikoff les deux font la paire 1 les
deux aces a révélé et les deux
j'aimerais pas être à des goûts tribunal
nicolas pernikoff oui pourquoi mais
d'abord je veux rebondir sur ce que vous
dites tous les citoyens ne peuvent pas
avoir une pleine page dans un journal
pour s'exprimer et donc
j'ai la même chose on le fait de
s'exprimer dans un interview soir c'est
pas la lan ouais le derrière lalanne
qu'est ce qu'on vise
on vise françois parce que france soir
on dit que c'est un site complotistes
c'est vraiment un journal et un journal
qui aimerait bien que france-soir
disparaît aujourd'hui c'est ça tombe
bien
excusez moi y est allé beaucoup trop
loin je pense qu'on est passé de l'autre
côté il a dit les grosses conneries
effectivement mais il ya juste un moment
donné il est allé beaucoup trop loin et
ça c'est la braye gilet jaune où ils
recommencent à donner des arguments
destituer le président la république
vous imaginez ou appeler l'armée enfin
il est là il ya des batteries des
limites à un moment donné il faut au
moins qu'ils aient je sais qu'il sera
pas qu'il ira pas en prison mais qui est
quand même un rappel à l'ordre
donc après notre question je vais poser
mais vous pouvez toujours pas répondu
moi je suis extrêmement étonné que
quelqu'un qui est domicilié je suis
désolé saouter donc peut-être vous
énerver mais il est domicilié en
belgique depuis pas mal de temps je
comprends pas pourquoi il s'intéresse
autant à la france aujourd'hui d'aussi
loin
voilà je suis je suis assez étonné à je
veux dire un pont si on prend tous les
artistes qui vit en belgique eu ces
questions je vais aller voter sur
l'excellent souvenez-vous première
question c'est la première question je
lui posais solesmes il s'en va je veux
dire amour de l'écrit ci qui m'explique
pourquoi ils s'intéressaient je veux
aller oui tous les gilles verdez m je
sais très bien que votre défense c'est
de dire derrière la novice france-soir
site complotistes dont le patron sera
d'ailleurs je crois convoqué également
pour être entendu mais quand même on
reprenons la loi l'atteinte aux intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation langues et en
mêlée l'anc est allé ouverte pour ça
c'est la sécurité nationale la forme
républicaine de nos institutions et la
sécurité de nos armées 106 la langue
dans sa tribune écrite pensée théorisé
ils cochent beaucoup de cases là dessus
monsieur c'est à dire ce que il appelle
effectivement l'armée à intervenir
c'est tout simplement illégal oui mais
j'entends de la façon il ya deux
lectures si vous voulez représente selon
le mail on le prend en disant qu'est ce
qu'il a voulu dire on essaie de
l'interpréter parce que c'est pas
forcément bien dit soit on le prend pied
de la lettre recherche à tout prix là
rien son pénales ont fini par la trouver
témoin je vous mets au défi de lire tout
ce qui a eu comme sottise aujourd'hui
dans les réseaux sociaux et vous allez
trouver
combien d'infraction à la sûreté
nationale j'étais sur le compte de
bachar des castanics hallucinant sur ton
d'abord neige et comment vous pouvez
répondre oui à cette question vous
pensez vraiment qu'il faut envoyer
francis lalanne un mec en prison parce
qu'il a il est écrit une tribune qu'il a
eu en plus il s'est excusé à demi-mot le
lendemain son plateau de jean marc
morandini
rigolez ou quoi forgues envoyé un mec en
prison pour ça on n'a plus droit de
s'exprimer on n'a plus droit de rien
dire
certes il a dit c'est pas un homme
politique c'est un artiste il l'a dit
avec ses mots c'est franchement qui
craint que francis lalanne mène un coup
d'état mais un ami vous êtes sérieux
mais ouais bah oui non mais sans rigoler
croyez quoi il en a pris puisque cet
argument je ne retiens pas parce que il
ya un climat d'ensemble qui me paraît
quand même très bien sûr regardez ce qui
s'est passé au capitole de washington
n'ont même pas parlé non mais je
regrette mais il ya des gens et même à
rien à voir excusez moi il ya des gens
qui prennent oxydes la même et c'est pas
les appels à l'insurrection annoncé le
président qui appellent à la grève
alors j'adore france et jouer notre mais
je vous dis qu'il ya un climat général
est il à la révolution il s'est passé
quoi rien voilà malheureusement la
dangerosité des propos doit être
proportionnelle aux gens qui le suivent
qui sont prêts à le suivre dans l'une
actions qu'il revendique comme ça mais
pour moi c'est juste un troubadour un
peu illuminée on met pro prison
quelqu'un qui fait l'amour en arbre
faute sérieux
veux-tu très belle entrée dans
l'émission merci ça me fait un peu
penser au film pour ce qui fut une
guerre game effectivement la question
c'est est ce qu'il faut mettre francis
lalanne en prison là c'est là si on le
faisait on serait vraiment plus dans un
état de droit une liberté d'expression
c'est très très grave
et qu'est ce t'as dit on était les
premiers gilles verdez tout le monde à
défendre la liberté d'expression c'est
un pamphlet alors on peut ne pas aimer
ce qu'il a écrit excusez moi moi je
n'aime pas du tout ni ce qu'il a écrit
nissan que vous lui avez dit vous l'avez
dit que la prestation mais écoutez alors
on peut pas avoir une liberté
d'expression a à deux vitesses un trou
c'est oui ou c'est non
ou est-ce que baker cela et après et
après général dans l'armée française il
a donc aucun pouvoir pour semer l'armée
française pour quand même pas exagérer
pas du tout l'expression n'est pas
illimité au nom mêlé des lois qui n'a à
la loi qui la règle générale la limite
c'est quoi cette histoire alors alors
alors chez alors je vais être alors dans
ces cas là on peut dès lors on peut tout
faire
on va voir on a merdé la wii a trop de
respect pour soi et regarder en face à
la dernière partition petit petit mot
pour vous dire que francis lalanne
il était lundi au conseil d'état avec
moi pour plaider la réouverture des
théâtres des salles de spectacles bravo
alain loyer qui nous fera que voilà la
jolie champions bah voilà
eh ben voilà et qu'on espère qu'il va
gagner et ben non dijon une connerie en
prison et vous l'embrassez lui escale
ils peuvent dire qu'il sera toujours le
bienvenu
voilà et puis s'il faut voilà benjamin
castaldi lui amènera faire aller les
shérifs